bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación un saludo a todos en efecto a
la corte constitucional despenalizó del
ecuador despenalizó el aborto en casos
de violación para toda mujer es el
aborto estaba es finalizado ya en el
ecuador en casos de violación únicamente
para mujeres con discapacidad la corte
constitucional amplía esta posibilidad
para cualquier mujer que haya sufrido
una violación y este esta decisión de
despenalización debo decir que es una
decisión que no se va a mover aún cuando
exista veto presidencial
en función de operativizar esta decisión
de que se regule está la interrupción
del aborto del del embarazo en casos de
violación la corte constitucional
dispuso a la asamblea nacional que cree
una ley que permita precisamente esta
está regulación y esta ley este proyecto
de ley font que se discutió y se aprobó
el jueves este jueves pasado en el 17 de
febrero y bueno por procedimiento
constitucional una vez aprobado el
proyecto de ley tiene que pasar al
presidente de la república para que lo
vete o lo sancione si lo beta que
significa que jeta
que no está de acuerdo con el proyecto
de ley pues tendría que regresar a la
asamblea nacional para volver a
discutirse no si la objeción es una
objeción parcial sobre todo pero estoy
aquí y en esto quiero ser enfática el
veto del presidente de la república no
mueve la decisión de la corte
constitucional
entonces en ese caso que hay caminos
legales o constitucionales le quedan al
activismo pro aborto un ecuador
la discusión en este punto va a ser una
discusión de plazos de requisitos es
decir del tema regulativo esta discusión
tendríamos que esperar primero a ver qué
es lo que ocurre con el veto del
presidente no hay una alta probabilidad
de que ese veto presidencial sea por
inconstitucionalidad porque el
presidente lo ha señalado y algunos
grupos autodenominados prohibida también
han señalado que está este proyecto de
ley vulnera el derecho a la vida como un
derecho constitucional si el veto
determina eso pasará a mano nuevamente
de la corte constitucional para
determinar sobre todo si los plazos que
se han establecido que en este momento
son de 12 semanas para las mujeres
adultas y de 18 semanas para las niñas
adolescentes y mujeres de la ruralidad
si ese plazo sobre todo es un plazo
inconstitucional pero la despenalización
como tal se va a mantener